(chopping sounds)
(upbeat music)
- [Zoe] The American South has long had
a taste for Mexican food.
But one chef has created a unique fusion
of his very own.
- I'm Zoe Saldana from BESE,
and I'm teaming up with Great Big Story
to shine a light on
American LatinX Excellence
around the country.
(fast upbeat music)
(clicking noises)
- [Zoe] Eddie came to the
U.S. as a teenager in 1974,
with just $140 in his pocket.
(running water)
- [Zoe] Today, he runs
a string of restaurants
in Georgia and Tennessee.
His success is undeniably due to his
clever approach to each dish.
(upbeat music)
- [Zoe] While Eddie utilizes
ingredients native to Mexico,
he keeps the American pallet in mind.
(upbeat music)
- [Zoe] For Eddie, each dish
takes time and experimentation.
But the end result is always worth it.
(dish scraping)
(upbeat music)
(chopping sounds)
(high pinging noise)